The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR:
Computational complexity
is basically about how
hard is a problem, right?
There are some problems
that are really easy
and some problems
that are really hard.
And Eric drew this
line on the board
where you have really
easy on the left
and really hard on the right.
What's the hardest problem
that we can possibly have?
AUDIENCE: It was chess, right?
Or something like that?
PROFESSOR: No, there's
something beyond chess.
AUDIENCE: A halting problem?
PROFESSOR: Halting problem.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Halting problem
is somewhere here.
So what's the best solution
for the halting problem?
Running time.
AUDIENCE: It is
exponential, or something?
PROFESSOR: You'd wish.
AUDIENCE: Oh really?
It's not even exponential?
AUDIENCE: I think
there's like no solution.
PROFESSOR: There is no solution
for the halting problem.
No matter how much time,
computers, and money you have,
you cannot solve
the halting problem.
It's undesignable.
So this is the worst kind of
problem you can come up with.
AUDIENCE: What exactly
is the halting problem?
PROFESSOR: So halting
problem is given
a program in any representation
that makes sense to you,
machine language, CE, assembly,
parsing tree, whatever
you want, decide if
it terminates or not.
Sounds really simple, right?
Turns out there's a proof that
says it's impossible to solve.
So you can't say will terminate
or will not terminate.
AUDIENCE: Well, but for some
programs, it's like while true,
but there's no break.
PROFESSOR: So Turing Machine.
Yeah.
If you have a machine where
you're not allowed loops,
then it's easy to know
what's going to happen.
So you need to have a
Turing machine, something
that allows loops.
So some instances
are easy, right?
But for the general
case of you have
to write a program that gets
another program and outputs
this bit, we don't
know how to do that.
But we've proven that nobody
will know how to do that,
so we're OK with it.
So this means undecidable.
We know that nobody will
ever be able to solve this.
So if you're given the halting
problem on an interview,
it's safe to laugh in the
guy's face and tell them,
why don't you show
me how to do it?
So what is better
than undecidable?
There are these problems here
that are outright impossible.
What's the next best thing?
AUDIENCE: Chess?
I know chess is in
there somewhere.
PROFESSOR: Chess is still here.
There's something
harder than that.
AUDIENCE: Is it R, or
something like that?
PROFESSOR: Yup.
So this is the boundary
for R and this whole thing
is R. What R?
R is-- so if these
are undecidable,
R means decidable, right?
So you can write an algorithm
that will compute the answer
and do that in a
finite amount of time.
Will the world end before
the algorithm ends?
Maybe, who knows.
But at least there's a
finite amount of time,
so the problem can
be solved somehow.
That means R.
AUDIENCE: R is like,
real, like it's not.
PROFESSOR: Real, OK.
AUDIENCE: So like numbers,
like, you know, real numbers--
PROFESSOR: So you know it
actually comes from recursive,
because some old people
decided that recursive
means it terminates
at some point.
This is really old
school stuff, 1940.
So R actually stands
for recursive.
Just know that R
means decidable.
Weird abbreviation, but oh well.
AUDIENCE: I'll go with real.
PROFESSOR: OK.
What's next?
So some problems are
in R. All the ones
that we care about are in r.
So what's better than r?
R means it's going to
terminate at some point,
there is a running
time for the problem.
What's the better than that?
Exponential, OK.
What does exponential mean?
AUDIENCE: Exponential?
PROFESSOR: Yup.
So the running time
looks like what?
AUDIENCE: 2 to the 10, or
something constant to the n?
2 to the n of the C?
PROFESSOR: For some
constant C, right?
So it's not just 2 to the n.
The moment you
have a 2 to the n,
we're like, OK,
if you're already
in this bad of a
situation, I don't
care if this is a polynomial.
I don't care if it's
an n or n to the 100,
you're already
pretty much screwed,
you're not going to solve
this before the world ends.
So that's what
exponential means.
Going to solve it, but
not before the world
ends for most
practical problems.
What's better than exponential?
AUDIENCE: NP.
PROFESSOR: OK, and
before we talk about NP,
let's talk about the
easy case, the problems
that we've talked about all
the time in the semester.
AUDIENCE: May I ask
you a stupid question?
What does NP stand for?
PROFESSOR: It's not
a stupid question.
It has a really hard to answer.
So the one-sentence
answer is NP stands
for non deterministic binomial.
And we're going to go
over that at some point
in the next few minutes.
OK, so what problems
have we talked about?
All the terms, except
for one problem,
for the knapsack
problem, the entire term
we talked about some
sort of problems.
Polynomial.
These are the
reasonably easy ones.
So polynomial problems are those
where t of n is n to the C,
so it's a binomial.
The running time is a binomial
in terms of the input sites.
Why does this matter?
If you have a
polynomial algorithm,
than if you double the
input, then the running time
is going to be 2 to
the C times n to the C.
So every time you
double the input,
the running time will
increase by a constant factor.
And you know what that is.
If your problem is exponential,
then if you double the input,
then the running time
increases quadratically.
It's not a linear increase.
Here it's a linear increase.
The factor isn't 2, but it's
still a linear increase.
Make sense?
So that's why we like
these problems, at least
we like them more
than anything else.
So polynomial problems
are the nice and easy ones
that we've talked about so far.
What does NP stand for?
Give me a practical definition.
AUDIENCE: You can
check it [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so NP means
that we can write the verifier.
I'm going to say exactly what
you said with different words.
That takes a solution
to the problem.
And of course, it has to
think the input to the problem
and tells us is it correct
or is it not correct.
And this very fire is NP.
So the very fire runs
in polynomial time.
Yes.
So if the verifier runs
in polynomial time,
what's the solution size
and what's the input size?
AUDIENCE: I think the-- I mean,
the solution said it's like 01,
right?
PROFESSOR: If we have
decision problems.
An algorithm that
solves an NP problem.
If you run it
against the verifier,
also has to convince you
that its answer is correct.
So the problems that we
talked about in class
were decidability problems
where you have to say,
is it possible to do this?
Yes or no.
When you have a
verifier with you,
then you have to output a string
that convinces the verifier
that your answer is correct.
So like if you
have a problem that
says-- if you have three
sets, for example-- that says,
given a logical expression, can
you assign variable values such
that the expression is true?
If I say yes, what
does that mean?
That means nothing.
How do I convince you
that my answer is correct?
I will have to give you
the assignment, right?
And then you can verify
in polynomial time
if my answer is right or not.
So the input to the
verifier, this solution,
is not necessarily the decision.
It's not just the
bit, yes or no.
So if the verifier runs
in polynomial time,
what's true about
the problem input
and what's true about
the problem output which
becomes an input
to the verifier?
They have to be
polynomial in size.
Otherwise, my
algorithm wouldn't be
able to consume
them fast enough.
So actually, polynomial
means that the running time
is polynomial in the input size.
So the input size is
automatically all set.
But the solution has to be
polynomial in the input size
as well.
And if you're thinking
decision problems,
you can be more rigorous
and call this a proof.
So if this proof is
binomial in the input size,
then if I'm really,
really lucky,
I can take the
input to a problem,
and I can flip coins and use
the corn results as bits,
and put them together,
and create the proof.
If I'm really, really lucky,
I'll get the right proof.
Chances of that
happening almost zero,
but if I'm really, really lucky,
conceptually I can get a proof.
This is what a non-deterministic
polynomial means.
It means that if you have
a magical machine where
you can flip a coin, and
it will always be lucky,
then you can output the
proof in polynomial time.
So far so good?
So this definition of a machine
that can flip random bits
is really useful, because we can
use it to build a common sense
proof that P is not NP.
There is no real rigorous
math proof that P's not NP.
That's worth a million dollars.
There is no proof
that P equals NP.
If you have proof
that P equals NP, then
that's worth a lot more.
And I will use that in
the common sense proof
that I'm going to show you now.
So we don't know if P is NP--
get it right-- if P is NP
or if P is not NP.
This is an open problem, and
there's at least $1 million
worth of prize money for it.
Let's talk about
an algorithm where
if you would know--
so if you would
be able to solve NP
problems in polynomial time,
you would be able to
make a lot of money.
A million dollars
is nothing compared
to what you could make
if you could do that.
So I'm going to use
that to convince you
that nobody knows how to
solve NP problems in P time.
Suppose you want to do
something really bad.
Suppose you want to
impersonate a bank.
So you guys probably
imagine that banks nowadays
don't transfer
money to each other
by sending trucks
with gold bars.
They do that every once in
awhile, but most of the time
the transfers happen very
quickly over the internet.
So banks have a
secure connection,
and they say, yo, give
me a billion dollars.
I'll give it back to
you in a few days.
Sure.
Done deal.
Now imagine what
you could do if you
could impersonate
one of those banks.
Sweet happy life in some
faraway place, right?
What would it take to
impersonate another bank?
It turns out that the
encryption algorithm that
use to secure this links
is an algorithm called RSA.
Do you guys remember that?
Heard about it?
So in RSA, each
party-- so each bank
has a secret key that
consists of two numbers--
P and Q-- big prime numbers.
And say each of these
are N-bit prime numbers.
And then they have
a probably key.
So they have a
number that announce
that is N equals
P times Q. So this
is announced to
the entire world.
This is public.
We went through this
[INAUDIBLE] set, right?
So this rings a bell.
They have to announce this
so that the other people can
encrypt messages for them.
If you want someone else to
be able to send you a message,
you have to tell them your n.
Now if you know P and Q,
you can decrypt messages.
So you can pretend
you're the bank.
Now let's set up a
problem in this way.
Given a verifier that
does long division--
so we have a verifier that
the verifiers input is N,
and some guess P,
P guess, right?
So the verifier will
compute N modulo P.
And if N modulo P is 0,
then it will say happy.
Actually, it will say,
you're rich as hell.
If it's not 0, then well,
tough luck, try again.
So if you could make
this verifier happy,
you could get P. So
given public information,
you could get the
private information that
would allow you to
impersonate the bank.
This is called a factoring
problem by the way.
So P and N are
usually 1024 bits.
So the chances of doing
that with a coin flip, no.
The chances of guessing it
are one in two to the 1024--
it's basically worse
than having to pick
a random atom in the universe
and choosing the right one.
So not going to happen.
But if you had an algorithm
that takes a verifier
and produces an input
that makes it happy,
then you would
solve this problem,
and you would
impersonate the bank,
become really rich,
and then the whole
world's economic system
would be in a
terrible situation.
AUDIENCE: P and Q
are primes, right?
So couldn't you just
find all the primes?
PROFESSOR: Well, so look at
it from this perspective,
the economic system
still functions.
It's not like everyone's
money disappeared somewhere.
Therefore, nobody was
able to pull this off.
AUDIENCE: Isn't there a
quantum algorithm to do it
or that's something different?
PROFESSOR: So this
assumes Turing machines.
We're assuming regular
Turing machines.
A quantum computer
breaks that abstraction.
For practical purposes, if
you had a quantum computer
that can manipulate
this many bits.
Then you would break RSA, and
the world would go to hell.
So hopefully by the time quantum
computers get this powerful,
we'll invent new security
algorithms that replace them.
But the fact that eCommerce
works now and that banks work
means that nobody
is able to solve
NP problems in polynomial time.
So by the way, factoring is not
the hardest type of NP problem.
Factoring is somewhere here.
OK.
Any questions about this part?
AUDIENCE: So factoring
is not an NP problem?
PROFESSOR: Factoring
is NP, but it's not
the most difficult
type of NP problem.
We'll get to those right now.
So this is a common sense
proof not the math proof
that NP is not P--
that at least nobody
knows how to solve NP
problems in polynomial time.
So there are these NP problems
that if you think about it,
the solution is
polynomial in size.
We can write a verifier
in polynomial time.
So why can't we write the
solver in polynomial time?
If you're a very high picture
guy like managerial type,
then you might think,
yeah why, can't you guys
just figure this out?
Like come up with an algorithm.
Isn't that what you guys do?
Well, so theory people
have been thinking
about this for 40 years or more.
So what do you do when
you think about something
and you can't come
up with a solution?
AUDIENCE: Say it's impossible?
PROFESSOR: You try to
say that it's impossible.
So you try to prove
that P is not NP.
But if you fail to do that
too, what do you do next?
AUDIENCE: Offer
a million dollars
to someone who can do it.
PROFESSOR: That too.
That might help.
Well, you complain that it's
really, really hard, right?
You want to go back
to your boss or you
want to go back to the world,
and say, we thought about this.
It is true that with thought
about it for four years,
but it's a really,
really hard problem.
Well, so for
undecidable problems--
so for the whole
thing problems, they
are able to convince the world
that nobody can solve this,
so we're all good.
So we couldn't come up with a
solution, because nobody can.
Here, we can't prove
that P is not NP yet.
So instead the next best
thing that theory people
could come up with
is-- they saw,
what are the hardest
kind of NP problems?
Let's look at them and let's
see if we can solve them
in some way.
And they found
some problems here
that are the
hardest NP problems.
And they called them
NP-complete problems.
And we'll see why
complete in a bit.
So these are the hardest NP
problems that you can have.
Factoring is not one of them.
Factoring is not
with the cool kids,
even though it
would make you rich.
There are some problems
that are harder than that.
OK so for these
NP-complete problems,
turns out there are a
few hundred of them that
would have practical
implications.
So you wouldn't be able
to get rich right away,
but still you'd be able to
solved the important problems
that would save
companies a lot of money.
So you think, if
there's a solution
someone would come up with it.
It also turns out that
they're all interrelated.
So if you can solve one problem,
you can solve all of them.
And you do that
through reductions,
which we'll go over in a bit.
But the bottom line
is there are hundreds
of NP-complete problems.
And if you solve one, then
you solved everything.
For now theory people
are trying to say,
look there are all
these problems.
If anyone would solve
any of them, all of them
would go away.
Nobody was able to
solve any of them,
so they must be
really, really hard.
This is the best they
could come up with.
This is NP complete.
AUDIENCE: This is same lecture
that you-- any problem that's
already [INAUDIBLE] transform
it into a different problem?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So if you have the
solution for one of them,
you could transform all the
other ones into that problem
just like we do with
graph transformations,
solve it, use the solution for
it to solve all the other ones.
So if anyone could solve any
of those hundreds of problems,
we'd have the solution to
all of them in an instant.
The fact that we don't
have a solution to them
means that nobody was
able to solve any of them.
AUDIENCE: Like there are some
problems like the chess problem
that can be solved
exponential time.
PROFESSOR: Those are different.
Chess is here.
AUDIENCE: So we can solve
chess though, right?
It's just exponential time.
Right?
PROFESSOR: As far as I know,
because it's exponential time,
there's no algorithm
that can actually
look at the entire configuration
space, and tell if you can win
or not.
So solving chess, what's chess?
Chess has given a board.
Can I win or not
from this board?
This would be very
useful in playing chess,
because you start with
the initial board,
and then for every
move you can make,
you look at the
resulting board, and you
say can I win or
not from that board.
If you're in a board
configuration in which you
can win, you don't want
to go to a configuration
where you won't be
able to win anymore.
So if you keep doing
this you eventually win.
So it would be really nice
to have this algorithm.
Yeah, we don't have it.
We don't have it and
chess is unsolved.
Wait.
AUDIENCE: So only things
that are below P--
but there are some algorithms
that run in exponential time.
They just take longer.
PROFESSOR: So the problem
is what's the input size?
Exponential in what?
If it's going to be-- if the
running time is 2 to the n,
and it's 10, then that's fine.
But for chess its exponential
in the board configuration.
And it turns out that there's
so many board configurations
that we don't have
computers fast
enough to solve the whole thing.
So deep blue goes to
a level-- to a depth
I think of somewhere around
15 and can barely competes
with humans, but it's not
guaranteed to win all the time.
So we don't have something that
has completely solved chess.
AUDIENCE: So we can only
solve things below P then.
PROFESSOR: We can only
solve things below P
fast, reasonably fast.
So what we care
about in this class
is how do our algorithm scale.
So do we have this or not?
Does your algorithm
scale or not?
The reason we don't like
algorithms that are after this
is that for problem sizes that
are really small like 8, 10,
or something small,
they're going to work.
But the moment the problem
gets bigger and bigger,
you're going to run
into a dead end.
AUDIENCE: Well, can
you use DP on chess?
PROFESSOR: You can
use DP until you
get to an exponential algorithm.
You might get to an
exponential algorithm
where the exponent is better.
So far all the smart
algorithms for chess
have reduced the
c here, but they
haven't been able to get
away from 2 to the n part.
If you make c smaller, sure
it's going to run faster,
and you can explore a
bigger part of the board.
But you're still not
going to be able to run
through the whole thing
before the world ends.
That's a good thing
to think about.
Will we solve chess
before the world
ends with the current
algorithms and machines?
No.
AUDIENCE: I guess.
Remember the Rubik's cube?
Wasn't that bordering
exponential or something?
I think Eric said that there
is order one solution where
the constant factor
is really high.
So that's different.
raises I think Tetris is
here, but the Rubik's cube--
AUDIENCE: It's in
the P, isn't it?
Yeah.
PROFESSOR: There's
a solution that's
order one with a high
constant [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: But our
brains can play chess.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
Our brains--
AUDIENCE: We can play chess.
PROFESSOR: Well, we can
play reasonably well,
but if someone could
play optimally,
they'd probably beat you.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can someone
play optimally?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: What about
machine learning?
PROFESSOR: Machine learning
problems are usually here.
That's why they don't
scale, and that's
why we've seen a lot of
interesting machine learning,
but so far I can't talk
to my computer right.
They can't make a
lot of progress,
because they have these really
hard problems that they're
working on.
AUDIENCE: There's Siri, right.
You can talk to Siri.
PROFESSOR: Yeah OK.
Sure.
I think I've seen
on the Internet
that it says some
awful things sometimes.
So I wouldn't
consider that solved.
So what does NP mean to
us like practical terms?
Here's how I see it, you're
on an exam or in an interview,
you start out with a problem.
Suppose all the
possible problems
are a graph, because
we work with graphs.
You have your starting problem.
This Is the problem that
you're trying to solve now.
Then you have a few
destination nodes.
Say you have merge sort.
We know how to solve.
If you can reduce your
problem to merge sort,
then you're in a good position.
You're writing your solution.
You're out of the room.
If you can reduce your problem
to a graph search algorithm,
so to BFS or DFS, you're done.
If you can reduce it to
shortest path, you're happy.
You're done.
If you can reduce it to a
dynamic programming problem
that we understand, you're done.
If you can somehow use hashing
or use divide and conquer
with an algorithm that we
studied, you're also happy.
So we have all these
destination points.
And what you're
trying to do is you're
trying to get from here all
the way to here via reductions.
So suppose you see
three reductions
that you could possibly do.
You don't have time to
work on all three of them,
so let's say you
choose the middle one,
because this one seems
like it's the easiest one.
So I'm going to
guess that this is
the easiest one I can tackle.
So now I'm going
to work on this.
I'm going to put the
original problem aside.
And I'm going to say if I can
solve this, then I'm happy.
Now say this turns into
three more reductions.
And this one looks promising.
it's a hard problem.
You have to do a few reductions.
It doesn't work right away.
But say I take this one
which looks promising,
and I'm able to reduce
it to a happy problem.
Reduction, reduction, reduction.
I write this up.
I'm done.
Exam solved or interview
question solved.
Now the problem
is what if instead
of going on this path which
is reasonably happy, what if I
go on a path that
looks like this?
All the reductions that
I can see from there
go really, really far
away from the problems
that I know how to solve.
Well you're going to
try some reductions,
and eventually you're
going to run out of time.
And this other interviewer
is going to say, yeah,
do you have any
questions about us?
Or the exam people will be like,
hey, can we have the exam back?
We want to go home now.
So this is a bad outcome.
Up until now, all you had
was good destination points.
So this is where
you want to reach.
Now we have these NP-complete
problems that we know are hard.
I've convinced you
hopefully that their hard.
So if you know some
NP-complete problems,
you also have some landmines.
You have some places
where if you got there
via reductions, not a good path.
You want to backtrack and
think of something else.
So for example if this
was an NP-complete problem
like if this reduction
then was, oh yeah,
solve [INAUDIBLE]
in polynomial time.
Let's see.
I don't know how to do that.
The world tried really hard.
Maybe I shouldn't try
this avenue on the exam.
So if you know that
this is NP-complete.
You stop right there.
You don't waste anymore time.
So this isn't time wasted.
If you understand NP-complete,
and you read the CLRS chapter
on NP-complete problems.
Then you also have
some sad faces here.
You have some land mines and
you know not to go there.
So now your space that
you're looking through
is a lot more bonded.
Hopefully, you're going to
have better chances of finding
a happy path, because not only
you have some destinations,
but you have some places that
you know you shouldn't go to.
So this is the point
of NP-complete.
You're probably really
busy at the end of the term
as we all are, so I'm
guessing you're not
going to have time to read
CLRS beyond what we really
ask you to read now.
But after you're done,
do yourself a favor.
For the sake of your
future interviews
and general happy
programming life,
read the NP-complete
chapter in CLRS.
Read the problem statements
and understand them.
Don't worry about the proofs.
Don't worry about the reductions
that say their NP-complete.
Read the statements.
Believe CLRS that
it's NP-complete.
And remember that whenever
you solve a problem,
you want to stay
away from those.
So those will be your landmines.
Those will be your sad spots.
Guaranteed, after you
do that, your interviews
will go a lot better,
because you'll
be faster at solving problems.
And that's what we
really care about.
So that's why NP-complete
is relevant in real life.
It gives us these data points.
Makes sense?
All right, I want to talk about
one NP complete problem that's
really important.
And that is SAT.
So SAT means satisfiability.
So given the logical
expression, find some values
for the variables
that make it true.
Let me grab an
example from here.
So in SAT your
expressions come out
in a really nice form, so
parsing isn't a big deal.
The way they come
out is there a bunch
of terms separated by AND.
So your expressions
look like this-- and,
and, and-- say we
have four terms.
These look good.
So you have some
terms, say n terms,
and they're all
separated by ANDs.
This is a term.
In a term you have
variables separated by ORs.
Nothing else.
Just either the
variable or a variable
with a NOT in front of it.
So say x1 OR NOT x2, NOT x1 OR
x4, NOT x3 or x4, and X2 OR X4.
So this is called the
Conjuntive Normal Form, CNF.
The reason this is really
nice to work with is-- OK,
you just have some
variables here.
You know that these
are all joined by AND,
so you're going to have to
make all these terms true.
And then you have ORs inside.
So you know that for
every term, at least one
of the things inside
the term has to be true.
And that's it.
This is the problem.
This is SAT.
You have n terms.
And then the number of variables
that you have inside is k.
So you have at most k
variables in a term.
This k looks like
a constant factor.
But it's so important
that in fact it
shows up in the
name of the problem.
The problem is called k-SAT.
And there are two
values of k for which
the problem is important.
There's 2-SAT,
and there's 3-SAT.
2-SAT is polynomial.
We have a solution that runs
in order and time in fact.
Really good.
AUDIENCE: But you're
saying that to make--
you're actually rearranging
things or you're just--
PROFESSOR: So I have to come
up with values for x1, x2, x3,
and four, so that the
whole thing is true.
And the expression
is already arranged
in this nice form for you.
AUDIENCE: It's just--
it seems like order
and, because you're just
evaluating to block, right?
PROFESSOR: Well, no, you have
to come up with the values.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I know.
I know.
But like--
PROFESSOR: OK and this
seems really easy, right?
Well, wait for it.
Wait for it.
2-SAT is polynomial.
3-SAT is NP-complete.
So if you solve it, you're
in turn for a Turing reward,
or you can become
really, really rich.
So n-SAT can be
reduced to 3-SAT.
So for anything
bigger than three,
n-SAT can be reduced to 3-SAT
using reasonable reduction.
So the input size
won't explode too much.
So why is this important.
This basically shows us
that 3-SAT is NP-complete.
And I can make a
three-minute proof
that 3-SAT is NP-complete.
Let's take that verifier
guy that we have there.
A verifier wants the
input, which already have
and the proof.
Let's write the
verifier as a circuit
that takes the input
and the proof as bits.
Those are input to the circuit.
The circuit is going to
evaluate to true or false.
Now that we have a circuit,
it's easy to turn that
into a logical expression.
Turn AND gate and OR gate
into-- and ANDs and ORs,
and then reduce N-SAT to
3-SAT and get one of these.
If you can solve
3-SAT, then you can
compute values for
the proof bits.
Bam.
That's it.
So I take the verifier and
I turn it into a circuit.
The circuit is all logic gates.
And then it has some inputs,
the original problem input
and the proof.
These are represented
as a series of bits,
and they're all
inputs in the circuit.
If the algorithm
is polynomial time,
then the circuit also has to be
polynomial in the input size.
Proof already has to be
polynomial in the input size,
so we're all good.
We're all in polynomial world.
Now we take this
circuit, and we turn it
into a logical expression.
Sorry not logical, logic, also
known as a Boolean expression.
So the input bits become
Boolean variables,
and then we express gates as
Boolean functions-- AND, OR,
NOT, whatever we want.
And this is going to
give us some expression.
That expression is going to map
to N-SAT for some value of n.
So then we're going to
take this expression,
and we're going to
reduce it to 3-SAT.
So actually we're going to
reduce the expression to 3-CNF
and then run 3-SAT on it.
The expression will
be reduced to 3-CNF.
So to something that
looks like this,
except you have three
variables inside everything.
Once it's in 3-CNF, you
can run 3-SAT on it.
If it is satisfiable,
then 3-SAT has
to give us some values
here for the variables.
Some of the variables are
the problem input-- Sorry
the problem input gets
hard coded in the circuit.
Sorry.
Not thinking here--
hard coded in circuit,
because we don't want it to
tell us what the input is.
And then the proof is
encoded as a series
of bits, which are
inputs in the circuit.
OK.
So problem hard coded, proofs
are inputs in the circuit.
We've taken the circuits, turned
it into an input for 3-SAT.
If 3-SAT says there is a
valid variable assignment,
then that assignment tells me
what the bits are in the proof.
So that means I can take the
proof, feed it to the verifier.
The verifier will
say it's happy,
so we solved the problem.
And this is true for
any NP-complete problem.
NP-complete means it has
to have a verifier that
runs in polynomial time.
So I have to be able
to follow this process.
So for the factoring
problem, for example, I
would take this
modulo algorithm,
I would express it as a circuit.
The bits of P
would be the input.
I take that circuit and I turn
into a 3-CNF formula, run it
on 3-SAT.
The variable values for
which the circuit happy
are the bits of P that make up.
So they're the bits of P.
They make up a factor of n.
So if I can run 3-SAT fast
enough to get an answer,
then I have P and
I have factor of n.
And I've become really, really
rich, and bye guys, I'm gone.
AUDIENCE: For each
of those expressions,
you said you make
that circuit n.
You've got all
these inputs, which
are x1, x2,
everything like that.
Could you just go through
every possible combination?
PROFESSOR: That's
exponential, right?
That's two to the n, where
n is number of variables.
And the number of
variables can be
proportional to the
number of terms.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That would be fine with it.
PROFESSOR: So that
means you have
an exponential running time.
It's not polynomial,
which is reassuring,
because otherwise it would mean
that the whole world has been
spinning their wheels around
nothing all this time, right?
So it's reassuring
that you can't
find the solution in two
minutes to this problem.
In fact, so far I've been
trying to convince you
that you should not
attempt to solve
this problem in real
time, so not on exam time,
not on [INAUDIBLE] time,
nor anywhere else where time
actually matters.
You guys bored?
Maybe.
Well, so there's
this proof that's
not too hard to follow that
says that if you solve 3-SAT
you have solved any
NP-complete problem by turning
the verifier into a
logical expression.
That's what it comes down to.
Now 2-SAT is polynomial.
And if you guys want, we
can go through the solution.
If not, we can skip that.
But this tiny difference
here, how many variables
you're allowed
inside, which looks
like it might be a constant
factor in an algorithm
actually makes the difference
between a very easy problem,
a problem that's in P, and
the hardest problem in NP.
So 2-SAT is order n,
so it's somewhere here.
3-SAT is all the way here.
Small difference how
many variables you're
allowed, two or three.
Makes all the
difference in the world.
AUDIENCE: There are logic
reductions you can make, right?
PROFESSOR: There are
optimizations that you
can make.
And there are some
people who do research
on how to solve 3-SAT in
a reasonably fast time.
Because if you solve
3-SAT, any problem
can be reduced to 3-SAT.
All right, we have a feeling
that we're not going to be able
to solve this in
polynomial time,
because a lot of people tried,
but some researchers are hoping
that well maybe you can solve
3-SAT in order of 2 to the n
to the power of 0.00001,
which exponential, right?
But you can solve many
problems with this.
Active research, so far I don't
think they've come very far.
Actually, I shouldn't
say that, because if you
apply the brute
force algorithm, then
you die at about 20 variables.
State of the art 3-SAT
solving algorithms,
I think it can handle
1,000 to 10,000 variables
in a reasonable time,
like a few hours.
There progress.
And that is all by doing the
reductions that you said.
You see some optimizations that
you can make in the expression.
You draw some
inferences, and you
explore the possible
configurations,
taking us part way.
So there's a lot of active
research going in that area
too.
So far, they didn't get here.
AUDIENCE: That's almost solving
NP-complete problem then,
right?
PROFESSOR: Well,
yeah, the thing is
in the end we care about
practical solutions, right?
So they're hoping to get
to a practical solution.
AUDIENCE: Well, a few
hours is pretty practical.
So that's for some problems.
Obviously they didn't
solve factoring, right?
If they would have solved
1,000-bit factoring in a few
hours, then we
would have noticed.
AUDIENCE: Maybe.
Seriously, OK.
PROFESSOR: We
would have noticed.
So far so good?
Any questions on this stuff?
So I want to reemphasize in
two minutes, the reduction
part of this.
So the reason why we
can solve, once we solve
one NP-complete problem,
we solve all the other ones
is reductions.
So we've done a lot of graph
transformations in this class.
We had three recitations and two
or three exam problems on that,
and I think we had some
homework problems on it
too-- a lot of graph
transformations.
Graph transformations
are just reductions.
You take some problem that looks
hard, and you do some magic,
and you build a graph that
represents that problem,
and you run shortest path on it.
Then you take the output for
the shortest path algorithm,
and you turn it into a solution
to the initial problem.
This means that we've
reduced those problems
to shortest path.
Well, you don't have to
reduce to shortest path.
If you have a problem that
you know how to solve,
you can take any other
problem and reduce to it,
and you've solved
that other problem.
So basically, here, if you
have your starting problem,
shortest path is
just one smiley face.
As long as you arrive
to any smiley face,
you're in good shape.
Of course, you
have to be careful
that while you're
doing you're reduction,
your problem size
doesn't explode.
So for example, if you take this
problem-- if you take 3-SAT--
if you take a 3-CNF
expression, and you reduce it
to the graph that has
3 to the n vertices,
and then you try to
run [INAUDIBLE] on it,
it was the running
time, 3 to the n.
Now I've got a new
polynomial, right?
So when you do the
reductions, you
have to be careful about what
happens to your input size.
And that's about it.
This is complexity theory.
It's basically one
big excuse for why
we can't solve some
problems that are hard.